what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are continuing on with Earth
x and god I love Earth X so much I love
this story it's so cool it's such a cool
idea a dystopian future in Marvel Comics
where everything in terms of like
history is still the same but like one
event happened and change the future of
everything
it's like Marvel ruins Marvel ruins ask
the question what would happen if people
actually you know if they actually gain
their powers in the real world earth
were actually exposed to the accidents
they gave them their powers in the real
world and it all turns out really dark
like it gets it's rural in that stuff
but again with the first story one of
the big things that was going on with
Captain America was that he had like
turned down the Office of the President
of the United States right and so
because of that like the American people
kind of turned their backs on him they
were just sort of like well then if you
don't want to lead us then we don't want
to be a part of what you have going on
and he kind of just became not really a
pariah so much is just an outlier he was
just a guy who was there and then this
was compounded by the fact that for some
reason somewhere along the line suddenly
everybody's sort of developing powers
and so it became kind of crazy because
now Captain America was obsolete because
everybody had power so there was really
no one for Captain America to really
rescue aside from those who were may be
injured or infirm or something along
those lines but a majority of people
could just save themselves but the whole
idea was that when he was dealing with
the Hydra which is basically just kind
of like a space organism that showed up
on earth and had taken over you know
like Jennifer Walters she-hulk and a
handful of other people and was trying
to spread itself outside of New York
that one of the individuals who have
been taken was wearing a Red Skull shirt
and that kind of set Captain America on
this path of trying to find the newly
returned Red Skull as he believed him to
be and so what this does is it leads us
to California and again this is kind of
crazy because like New York itself
California has basically fallen and
that's one of the themes that you guys
are gonna notice here that for the most
part where we would believe that like
the rise of superpowers on earth would
lead to a kind of Age of Heroes in the
sense that it would basically be this
place where we'll be almost utopian
where it would be like a higher state of
being and everything would be better and
so on and so forth instead it became
this kind of land off do as you please
to quote V for Vendetta and so the
result is that people just kind of do
whatever it is that they want to and it
gave rise to petty warlords because for
those individuals who gained powers but
never took the steps necessary to learn
what it meant to have power
they've just suddenly realized they can
do anything they want to and so leading
up into California itself again like New
York it's basically collapsed she's kind
of like this place where things happen
and stuff goes on and that's
really about it and a petty warlord has
effectively risen to power now what is
up happening here is in the middle of
all this
Namor the Submariner returns I remember
we talked about this in the last video
name of the Submariner it killed Johnny
Storm when Namor had allied himself with
Doctor Doom and a fight broke out
between these two groups in the ER
against this group and the Fantastic
Four and so the result was that with the
death of Johnny Storm Franklin Richards
freaked out and he basically uses
reality-warping powers and forced one
half of the body of namely the
Submariner to burn anytime he wasn't in
water and so as a result he basically
makes his presence here and kind of pops
up because people are essentially
infiltrating the Seas and they're going
through and kind of doing whatever they
want and he really kind of stood
considered to be like an affront more or
less like breaking into a man's house
that kind of a thing and so the result
is that we actually moved from that and
switch over to Peter Parker with his
daughter who's become venom now I want
you to notice something here and this is
something that I thought about talking
about in the last video but I thought it
would be more pertinent to talk about
here Peter Parker is nothing like he
used to be the whole nature of Peter
Parker when it comes to him being
spider-man historically speaking in
Marvel Comics is yes he has his ups and
downs he has his good times and his bad
times but the idea is that for the most
part Peter Parker is optimistic he
really sees like the glass half-full and
because of that he's very much one of
these characters is kind of like a
bright shining star in Marvel Comics
that I would necessarily say people
idolize but he certainly brightens up a
story a little bit if it's going in a
darker direction but in this instance
Peter Parker's cynical he's really kind
of like you know there's no need for us
here anymore there's no need for us to
be superheroes and that's kind of funny
because it almost indicates that Peter
Parker's perspective of himself in the
world walks the knife's edge Peter
Parker sees himself as relevant only so
far as there's someone for him to
protect now he also of course has you
know was married somewhere along the
line
hence the birth of Mayday Parker we can
probably assume it was Mary Jane Watson
I don't believe we're explicitly told at
least not that I recall but the fact
remains here that somewhere along the
line the daughter of Peter Parker gained
the venoms Simeon and this is kind of
interesting because Peter's initial
stance is no matter how hard you try in
the end it will take you over but the
indication here is that made a partner
is actually in control of the Venom
symbiote not only that Peter and his
daughter are basically not really
estranged so much as they're not really
close to each other they're not like the
kind of relationship you would expect
with a father and a daughter you know
kind of providing these pearls of wisdom
teaching his daughter how to become a
woman how to function as a superhero and
that's what's so ironic about this is
because in a lot of ways Peter was one
of the first he was one of the first
superheroes to
rise to prominence in Marvel Comics and
so if ever there were a person to
basically be tutored under its Peter
Parker and so that's what's so ironic
about this is Peter being one of the
really kind of like the face of Marvel
Comics one of the foremost heroes is no
longer a hero he's just an aging guy
that just kind of exists he just kind of
floats from one day to next and he will
until he dies it's the saddest thing to
see a person who exists but doesn't
really live so again from here we switch
back over to Reed Richards now again
what we talked about in the last video
was it Reed had basically taken over
Liberia he had taken over the mantle of
Doctor Doom not in the sense that he'd
become like a villain it's not like Reed
Richards put on the outfit of a Victor
Von edema was like I am now the new
Doctor Doom he just kind of taken up
residence there in Latvia and the whole
basis behind this was you know the death
of the Fantastic Four basically you know
Susan and Johnny Storm truly the rise of
superpowers among the entirety of the
Planet Earth all that rests on the
shoulders of of Reed Richards and the
reason for this is because what Reed had
done is he had basically access or
learned about vibranium inside of
Wakanda and because he and Black Panther
were such close friends and because
there was just like an energy shortage
across the world what ended up happening
is Reed had actually gone to Wakanda
petitioned uh you know T'Challa use
vibranium and intended to basically turn
sound ways to convert sound waves into
energy light and different things like
that that could in turn basically power
the world what it meant is that the
world would achieve like a higher state
of being it would achieve a greater
enlightenment humanity wouldn't have to
focus on whether or not people in their
countries have enough to eat or whether
or not they have electricity or they
have running water or anything like that
all those would be a foregone conclusion
that was alternate li the idea of read
but notice this this falls in line with
the nature of read now in truth the idea
of like trying to fix the problem of
everything that didn't come until almost
a decade after this story was written
but that was the natural progression
when Jonathan Hickman introduced that
into Reed Richards it wasn't a paradigm
shift for his character it wasn't a
total 180 a man who's obsessed with
science a man who's obsessed with fixing
the world's problems the most natural
progression is to solve the problem of
everything but where Reed is you know a
guy who's known for science the truth of
the matter is that read is a slave to
science and so in this instance when he
was trying to solve the world's problems
because it went awry he's basically kind
of stuck in his own you know inner hell
more or less of trying to figure out the
solution what went wrong
where did I screw up what happened you
know that's really all it is that's the
governing factor that controls his life
what happened what went wrong and what
can be done to fix it and he lives his
life day in and day out trying to find
an answer to that question he's
literally governed by his own mistakes
and so the result is that when he
basically offers his explanation when he
says look somewhere along the line
something happened and there was some
kind of an explosion and this energy
this vibranium energy was basically just
dispersed throughout the entirety of the
planet Earth and suddenly people started
gaining powers the factor is what caused
it because reads reads idea is that the
vibranium energy caused it but we know
that's not the case vibranium doesn't
give people powers it doesn't work that
way
and so the result is that something had
to happen vibranium was the means by
which it could be transmitted but like
something had to give people powers and
the question is what was that thing and
that's what read hasn't figured out yet
and so we're the Inhumans kind of talk
about if we had enough time we could
probably figure it out when read says
the catalyst he used to achieve this was
vibranium suddenly heads start turning
and the reason why is because somewhere
along the line the Inhumans abandon
earth when everybody started getting
powers to be Inhumans left there was no
reason for them to be there anymore the
Inhumans left to basically colonize a
new world and to start over again but
when they got through they discovered
another world where basically it had
been totally destroyed and obliterated
but the people who inhabited that world
were encased in a kind of material of
sorts but they were still alive they
were just kind of in a state of
suspended animation and where the
Inhumans had considered rescuing them
what they discovered was that the source
of this explosion at least it seemed was
vibranium and so that's really kind of
what they bring to the table is look if
what you did was used vibranium and
somehow that in turn gave everybody
powers in one form or another meaning
that you basically used it as an energy
source and dispersed it across the world
you've doomed the planet because we
don't necessarily know exactly what it
was that caused that planet to erupt but
what we do know is that vibranium was
tapped into it somehow now if you know
the truth about what happened do not
spoil it I swear to God I will
I would like punishments will be handed
down swift and harsh but it's cool this
is one of those things were it's like
everybody has a piece of the puzzle but
it turns out the puzzle they're solving
is not the actual puzzle they're looking
for it so that's what's cool about this
whole thing but switching back to name
with a submariner
the whole situation with him again like
he's just kind of like rallying these
folks up and that's traditional name war
stuff I mean one thing to bear in mind
is that name
and Aquaman are very similar when it
comes to that regard I mean name war
appeared before Aquaman but they weren't
Aquaman a very you know similar in that
regard in the sense that it is one of
those scenarios were their allegiance is
to the sea you know Aquaman name of the
Submariner you know they've been part of
their own respective superhero teams
they mores been an avenger Aquaman's
been part of the Justice League but when
the question is asked if you have to
choose between like your superhero team
and the superheroes of Earth and like
Atlantis which one do you guys pick and
they always choose Atlantis every single
time without fail they never that they
never hit that markets I'm a king first
and a superhero second and that's the
role that name was a submariner place
the problem with this is that while he's
basically going on a rampage in New York
and Captain America and in you know
Wyatt Wingfoot are watching it all
unfold suddenly Namor stops he eats idli
just stops and calms down and that's it
and just descends down to the surface
and slowly starts walking towards some
person and that's what we end up finding
out the Red Skull is not the Red Skull
it's just some teenage kid
who is somehow managed to take the
entirety of California and place the
entire state under his control now at
this point we kind of go on to a side
mission of sorts with Reed and the
Inhumans and the reason why is because
remember when it comes to the Inhumans
the whole reason that they're here
they're supposed to basically be finding
a prince of sorts a person who's
supposed to be marrying Luna the
daughter of Quicksilver and crystal as
soon as they find that person presumably
they would just leave they would say
okay cool it's time for us to go again
and they would just kind of bail out and
so the whole idea for Reed is to
basically you know offer some measure of
help again kind of feeding into the idea
of him trying to solve his own problems
calm these inner demons so to speak but
what it would also do is help to give
some insight potentially into how it was
everybody got powers and so the result
of this is that where Reed initially
sits down and says it seems almost
impossible to differentiate between the
Inhumans and basically mutated humans it
suddenly dawns on him to grab cerebro
you know now of course mostly everybody
knows who saw you know what cerebral is
the device that Xavier used to basically
locate mutants on earth to differentiate
between humans and then those who had an
X gene but it is kind of cool because
Brie's response is well we can modify it
and we can basically use that to find
like any humans and then from those
Inhumans we can sort out who this prince
is that you're supposed to be locating
and who it is is supposed to marry Luna
now at this point we switch back over to
Captain America again and this is really
really cool it's like one of the coolest
moments in the whole story because one
is up happening here is Captain America
basically approaches this young kid and
essentially says you can't do this now I
remember Captain America is basically
holding on to a dead ideology he's
holding on to the realm of freedom
basically saying people should have the
right to live their lives as they see
fit but that's what you're seeing here
people achieved ultimate freedom when it
came to everybody having superpowers and
instead of saying okay we should do this
responsibility people just descended
into madness and chaos so sure people
have freedom and they use that freedom
to destroy themselves and so because of
that Captain America is just kind of a
relic he's an archaic thing he's not
relevant anymore and so when he
approaches this kid and starts talking
to him the initial response of the kid
is hey look I can do anything I want to
and that's when it starts to dawn on
Wyatt Wingfoot and Captain America that
this kids power is mind control and
that's what he's doing he's mind
controlling every single person in this
vicinity and has them all under his
command what he's also doing is
effectively building an army because
like so many petty warlords that exist
in the United States right now
what you have are people who realize
I've got powers and I can use these
powers to give myself even more power
and that's what a ton of people are
doing but where Captain America steps in
and goes to attack this kid suddenly he
gets a flashback and he sees Bucky
Barnes and that's the power of this kid
notices this kids power is almost
identical to like mastermind jason
wyngarde now that's kind of one of those
funny such funny situations when it
comes to like powers and Marmol comics
in a lot of ways a lot of them are
basically identical they're just used in
different ways or they have little
caveats the power of jason wyngarde is
to manipulate the five senses whatever
you can like see touch smell taste and
hear he can manipulate it so we can take
away your sense of taste he can take
away your sense of smell or he can make
you believe that if you're eating a
piece of pizza that you're actually
tasting a lemon there's all kinds of
different things that he can do with you
not the effect of him doing that is the
exact same effect as if Charles Xavier
controlled your mind and made you
believe that you were somewhere else it
all has it all kind of comes out to the
same thing well the fact remains you
know kind of going off this tangent in
this story Bucky Barnes again you know
is basically dead he's a long since been
dead
there is no Winter Soldier Bucky Barnes
died he's been dead all this time as
well the cool thing about this is that
in this instance Captain America is
literally hallucinating that he's in
World War two and that he's trying to
save Bucky Barnes but where he starts to
freak out and then eventually snaps out
of it why at Wingfoot is basically taken
over and then this huge army of of Red
Skull just kind of descends down onto
Captain America
and the result is that where they're all
screaming and they're all basically
saying we don't want to do this you have
to help us we don't want to be the ones
that are doing this we don't mean to
hurt you Captain America has to
effectively abandon everyone and run
away
and that's what's so screwed up about
that it's Captain America who
effectively walks out on humanity yet
again and that's was kind of crazy is
because we would expect Captain America
to stay there and fight but it's also
one of those things of runaway live to
fight another day but find a way to
bring this down and set the world back
to rights and that's kind of the cool
thing about Captain America in this
instance but at this point we basically
jump back to New York
essentially with I think it's I want to
say it's Betty Ross uh who was mutated
and ended up you know becoming like this
demon looking thing this crazy-looking
thing and where she's initially set upon
by Hydra they're met by the arrival of
the Incredible Hulk and Bruce Banner now
this is kind of interesting as far as
I'm aware I don't believe we're given an
explanation as to why it is the
Incredible Hulk and Bruce Banner are two
distinctly different people although now
that I think about it I think we are
given an explanation I mean it's not in
this particular part of the story but I
think we are given an explanation in
terms of like how the whole thing with
Banner and the Hulk works the way this
works is that banners basically blonde
and he sees through the eyes of the
Incredible Hulk so it's kind of cool uh
but it is an interesting scenario
because basically hoaxes almost like
this giant gorilla form which it's kind
of cool to be honest but the whole idea
is to essentially show up to basically
go visit you know dr. strange of the
sanctum sanctorum but when they get
there when they get to where the
sorcerer supreme is at of course they
are met by Wang but what we end up
discovering is that dr. strange isn't
here instead the current sorcerer
supreme is the niece of Dormammu also
known as Clea with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
if you are new here two comments
explained make sure you guys at the sub
button to become part of the robb cork
do you guys enjoy this video make sure
you drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
you